so in the first part of my talk I'm
going to discuss the duality between
robustness and evolutionary decay and
the argument is that as systems acquire
mechanisms that protect them from
external perturbations and those
mechanisms which protect the system from
perturbations also shield internal
components of the system from direct
environmental challenge so systems
acquire mechanisms that protect them
shield the internal components the
internal components are not exposed as
directly to the external challenge and
will tend to decay over evolutionary
time so there's a natural duality
between robustness and decay and I'll
suggest that this duality between
robustness and decay influences the
evolutionary dynamics of the design of
biological architectures and biological
computations so that's the first part of
the talk in the second part of the talk
I'm going to look at general aspects of
input-output relations in biology you
can think of inputs as sensors or
measurements of extrinsic information
and the outputs is the computational
transformations of those inputs and one
interesting pattern that often occurs
and input/output relations in biology is
that we see switch like behavior that is
to say when the inputs are low the
output stay low and then over a very
narrow range of inputs the outputs
switch to a high level so we're getting
a switch which is basically a analog to
digital converter plays an important
role in building components of
computational architectures in biology
and the puzzle with these switches is
how they arise from biochemistry because
the basic laws of mass action chemistry
don't look like that basic laws of mass
action chemistry give us an input output
relation that is not at all switch light
and so the puzzle that occurs is the
mechanisms by which biology builds such
analog-to-digital switches and one
reason for focusing on this is that it
forms a nice little model for
understanding the little pieces that
build circuits for biological
computations and one of the arguments I
want to make is that in order to
understand these these computations that
you need to
pay attention to the aggregate structure
of input-output relations that is to say
inputs come in and they're transformed
in multiple ways before you get outputs
and so if you look at the aggregate
structure the input output relation you
can understand things a bit more deeply
which is just to say that aggregation
matters which is a very widespread and
well-understood point and the second key
issues that we need to look at scale
transformation so we're led to the
classic aspects of aggregation and scale
and understanding these components I
think this will help us to understand
the design of biological systems so the
first parts about the duality between
robustness and decay and the second part
about input-output relations and all
those of those may seem like very
different topics towards the end I'll
suggest that there actually closely
related through this notion of
understanding aggregate structure so
that's that's the talk so let's go to
the first part of the talk which is the
duality between robustness and decay and
let me introduce this by giving you a
little story about the history of
computer hard drives very crude story
but think of capture the essence of my
main point if you're old enough to
remember 30 years ago you'll remember
that when you bought a computer hard
drive at hurt cost a lot of money and
typical mid-range computer systems that
were using companies often stored data
on single hard drives that were very
expensive and Nicole was to engineer
them to high tolerance and low error
rate but over the last 30 years has been
a real change in the architecture of
data storage and sort of mid-range
computer systems now almost all
mid-range computer systems that
companies use use redundant array of
independent disks or raid arrays and
what a raid array does is when the data
come in to be stored is broken up into
little chunks and spread across a series
of disks and a form of redundancy but
it's not just simply making copies like
backup copies it's more complicated than
that and the data are stored occurred
across these different disks and the
locus of design has shifted instead of
being engineering the individual hard
drives to high tolerance and low error
instead there's a board of logic that
sits above the system and controls the
system so the data come in and this
board controls spreading the data out
and recovering the data
so really we've had is a shift in the
locus of design from the focus on
engineering the individual discs to high
tolerance to entering the system to high
tolerance with the focus on the
controller board and associated with
that and this is the interesting point
is that in effect what's happened is
that people and companies now use
cheaper lower performing sloppier hard
drives it doesn't pay to have a very
expensive hard drives because in these
were dumped in systems if a hard drive
fails you just pull it out and stick
another drive in and so companies tend
to use sort of modestly performing
relatively cheap drives that are not
engineered to the tolerance that could
be achieved and I think this process of
the migration of design focus of design
and control to a higher level to achieve
better system performance associated
with a decay in the performance of the
individual components is something that
inevitably happens in the history of
design I think it's been very important
in biology so you can sort of think the
logic is very simple and probably you
can see the logic now what I would like
to be able to do is give you a whole
series of examples showing you how you
can understand the history of
evolutionary design computational
architectures and biology based on this
argument but in fact I don't have a good
example so I'm going to relatively weak
position but nonetheless I think it's
very important and so what I want to do
is give you a couple of predictions
about how I think we can begin to see
how this idea might work i should also
say that one interesting consequence of
the idea is that there's an
irreversibility once you get a higher
level controller you get a decay in the
underlying components you can't take
away the higher level controller because
the components no longer perform
sufficiently for the system to survive
or to function properly so there's an
irreversibility in the history of
evolutionary design in this way
prokaryotic do eukaryotic gene
regulation sounds like an example but
it's not so we get back to it so the
example that I want to give you which I
think and this is just a hypothesis but
one of the things that's come up with
high throughput genomics and the ability
to measure lots of things until a few
years ago the measurements were
always done in aggregates you couldn't
measure single cells the technology
wasn't there but that's changed in the
last couple of years and people can now
measure the protein levels in the
messenger RNA levels and single cells
and one of the discoveries which some
people think is surprising I don't is
that there's a high level of
stochasticity from cell to cell if you
look at the protein expression levels
and so thinking about that this is the
way I would think about in terms what I
just said if you imagine a tissue
composed of many cells and you think of
the function of the tissue is being to
secrete a hormone or an enzyme that
works at a distance right then what
matters what matters is the average
secretion rate per cell and the
variability among the cells doesn't
matter at all put that another way the
best way to achieve high precision is to
aggregate a lot of components because
the variance of the average is very
small once you do that you achieve a
high level of robustness in some sense
you can use a lot of sloppy components
you have a lot of precision but the
selection in each the regulatory design
in terms of the tolerance of each cell
have really created a situation you can
have very poor tolerances purcell you
expect the high level of stochastic city
at the cellular level contrast that with
the situation for example let's say in
bacteria bacteria often secrete enzymes
to digest resources in the local
neighborhood outside of the cell
bacteria might be secreting enzymes to
secrete to digest these resources and if
we think of a viscous environment where
the diffusion rate is low cell density
is low then what a single cell does
matters for its ability to acquire
resources so the functional level is
actually at the single-cell level and so
we expect the regulatory system to be
designed to much higher tolerance and
lower sloppiness so we get a simple
prediction based on the level of
function you need to pay attention to
the level of function we get predictions
about the degree of sloppiness this is a
very simple way to make a prediction
about the observations that are coming
in about the level of stochasticity
that's observed in different systems I
wouldn't be surprised if somebody else
has said a variety of things like that
in the literature the literature's big
pretty much everything gets
it's on lame originality but it's not
the dominant view in the literature and
I think this gives us some way of
looking at these problems so that's in
essence the first part of the talk and I
think that the main point is that if we
want to look at the evolutionary history
of the computational architectures as
they've evolved and are designed by
biological processes we need to
understand the sort of weird feedback
that happens with robustness or
insensitivity or the migration to higher
levels of control and the decay of the
underlying components and I think that's
going to give a real directionality to
evolutionary history so the main
arguments here are in a couple of papers
or some other is now adaptation in the
paradox of robustness and the evolution
of robustness and cellular still cast is
you know there's a huge literature in
biology about robustness most of it
focuses on genetic variability doesn't
focus I'm like the key to my argument is
that anything that makes the system
insensitive to perturbations changes the
internal marginal costs and benefits and
the design of the components that were
there previously and I think that that's
the I don't want to say novel because
I'm sure you can all find some precursor
to my idea but not what's often
discussed in the literature although
there's a huge literature on robustness
so that's the first part of the talk
we'll come back to that at the very end
now I want to turn to the second part
which is this analysis of input/output
functions in biology and I've told you
that we often have switch like behaviors
that we observe and that the key puzzles
that that contrasts with basic laws of
mass action chemistry so here's basic
mass action chemistry Michaela Menten
kinetics which is sort of the foundation
of any biochemical analysis and this is
the sort of pattern you would expect for
an input output relation based on
Michaela Menten kinetics here you
imagine some input signal coming in at
concentration s and imagine that the
cells have some non active molecule
that's around in some concentration and
what s does is transforms the inactive
molecule to an active state right so the
greater s the greater the concentration
of the active molecule so that's all the
signals driving the
activation of a particular molecule
macayo's man kinetics for a classic
reaction would tell us that the input
output relation would be a diminishing
return and that's sort of the basis that
we use for doing any biochemical
analysis but you can see biologically
that that's already a little bit weird
because think about it that says that
you're getting maximum sensitivity an
infinitesimal concentration of an input
which if you know anything about biology
or you think about biology just doesn't
sound right you're not going to getting
maximum sensitivity that infinitesimal
concentrations and in fact many
biological and put out but relations
look like that they're more switch like
analog to digital and this is so common
an input output relation that it has a
name the hill equation pattern and the
hill equation pattern is discussed in
the history of biological literature
over the last hundred years is a vast
literature on this and one of the
interesting things is that this very
simple S shaped pattern arises in many
different scales from biochemical
reactions done in isolation in the
laboratory to input output relations and
cellular systems and regulatory controls
and systems biology systems biologists
frequently invoke the hill equation
pattern in order to build their little
circuits and their models and it's the
fundamental equation that's used to fit
dose-response curves that the whole
organism level that is to say if you
take a whole animal and you're treated
with the concentration of a drug how
does the animal respond to the drug
that's in pharmacology and dose response
curve the fundamental method for
analyzing dose-response curves is the
fit a hill equation to it the hill
equation is incredibly simple if we do a
non dimensional form and input X and an
output Y we have one parameter K which
gives us the different curves that are
fit if k equals 1 we have makayla
smacking class act classical mass action
chemistry as K increases you get a more
switch like behavior but the remarkable
thing is that this incredibly simple
equation actually gives a fairly
remarkable fit across a huge range of
scales in biology so most of our going
to talk about is from this article in
put out the relations
biological systems measurement
information in the hill equation so in
biology this switch like behavior is you
often call by stability because the
system is stable e in an off state until
the sale gets strong enough and dries it
to a stable on state so it's the
question is how does the signal drive
the system from one stable state to
another so questions by stability it
soft enough it's often discussed also is
ultra sensitivity because the system is
ultra sensitive to changes in a narrow
range so this is very useful in terms of
components and architecture for
computational systems and biology and is
something that's seen quite frequently
and so people wonder about where does it
come from and so here's just one example
of a study the literature and this is
vast but here's one study which i think
is is well done and the question here is
the regulatory control of mitosis
mitosis is cell division you can imagine
that if a cell for controlling cell
division you either want to sell to be
in a non dividing state or going through
division it doesn't pay to be kind of
dividing and so you need some sort of
analog to digital converter and in
particular in this case cdk1 is one of
the regulatory molecules which is
important in driving this the cell into
a mitotic state cdk1 modifies this
particular molecule and so is this
molecule which is actually in this
particular case uses the proxy for
determining the degree to its cdk1 is
driving the sell it to the mitotic state
and you get a nice Hill equation pattern
with a hill coefficient of about 3.5 now
in this article the author's pose the
puzzle exactly as I posed it classic
Michaela Menten kinetics predicts this
but what we see is this so the question
and here when I'm really going to
emphasize for especially from people in
computer science is the mindset you've
got a pattern you've got to find the
molecular generated mechanism that's the
gold molecular biology how do you
generate that pattern based on molecular
process so what they say is several
generative mechanisms can in principle
give rise to ultra sensitivity and then
here's a list of three classic
generative mechanisms and so you have a
shopping list of generative mechanisms
microscale mechanisms that generate the
pattern and you want to figure out which
of those is operating in this case so
you do a study and you figure it out and
there cuz i mean the very simple one of
just everything only dimers or trimers
there's lots of them that one on your
list i have a longer list coming up
relax so the mitotic regulator so this
is the conclusion from their article the
mitotic regulators can inactivate each
other through inhibitory chemical
modifications phosphorylations and then
this is their main conclusion there's a
double negative feedback loop that forms
a bistable trigger it makes the
transition into mitosis digital okay so
that's the conclusion from their article
now that's fine I don't have any real
criticisms of that in fact they're
probably correct because it's a very
good lab and I'm sure the study was done
very well but I have a little
reservation deep inside of me which says
when you get a pattern that that's
simple that matches an equation which
has so simple across every scale in
biology that workers over and over and
over again maybe always fitting little
micro scale processes to the pattern
isn't the right way to think about the
problem in fact what I think is I see
that okay that is a Gaussian or normal
distribution no biologists would see a
pattern from study that was a Gaussian
pattern and try to come up with a
specific generative mechanism to explain
that pattern they all know that this
arises by the aggregation of a bunch of
sloppy things you'd throw a bunch of
things together you add them up and you
get that somehow that was trained
everybody kind of gets that any other
pattern in biology deserves a very
special microscale explanation now it's
not true that the dowsing is the only
attractor in the world there are others
we'll get back to that issue say it
blooming that's actually when the hill
equation was developed and if you look
at the history of the studies in
hemoglobin you see that with more data
it became clear that the hill equation
is not a good model in other words you
yeah that's a dead sir I know the
history of the whole equation and I was
talking about that because that's
irrelevant for what I want to say no no
what I mean is that eventually just
because it's true doesn't mean it's
relevant no no what I mean is that
eventually you got to the point where
the molecular structure makes
conversions between two states right hi
I know although it's not relevant for
what i want to say if you want to talk
about the molecular biology of
hemoglobin we can have a discussion
about the molecular biology be no clue
but it's not it's not the key point I
understand the distinction between
specific explanations for specific
molecules in the history of how people
have understood the hill equation but my
main point is that in spite of the fact
that some people understand hemoglobin
that Rick over and over and over again
when people see the hill equation
pattern in molecular biology you don't
give you some examples in a minute that
people have tried to make microscale
generative explanations rather than
thinking about the problem as
potentially new tractor and that's
because biologists don't recognize any
attractor except the Gaussian that's it
of course that's not one hundred percent
true because lots of people understand
the power of aggregation the prize for
the best title goes to Stuart Kaufman
the origins of order order is pattern
the origins of order to Kaufman he
understood that aggregation was very
powerful in creating pattern and that's
what his book is about and so I think he
really understood this fairly deeply for
molecular biology he had the right idea
it's a if you ever tried to read the
book and you've gotten anything out of
it I'd like to talk to you
it's full of good ideas but they're
sorts a very chaotic book but but I
think we have to give him credit because
he did understand very deeply this issue
and he ain't breathin this really is the
heart of the book in spite of the fact
that he tried to explain everything else
on top of it and so that was the foam
and there's other people Nick Barton has
over the last several years developed a
program which with considerable success
and evolutionary genetics and looking at
the powerful role of statistical physics
and I think this is an ongoing project
which is continue to develop there's a
lot of success here in ecology there's a
long history of looking at aggregation
yo I was--and Simon live in 25 years ago
wrote some nice articles and this is
developed into a subfield of ecology so
it's not that I'm the first person to
think that statistical physics might be
interesting but in spite of these
beautiful developments and beautiful
articles and these are really this is
all these really good work this is a
tremendous this is a very tiny minority
and the way biologists think about
problems they do not think this way
generally instead you get distinction
you've got a pattern you come up with a
microscale explanation to fit the
particular pattern and it in fact you
might be correct in any particular case
so I argue with the particular cases but
I get suspicious because this pattern is
so simple about whether always they're
getting the right answer I continue to
see this I see attractors I see
aggregation as being often the best
explanation for this sort of thing now
let me try to convince you a little bit
you know my guess would be for the the
threshold on the tractor involves
selection whereas for the Gaussian
incident
tractor that's operating by processes
the darting according to selection is
that a distinction that Matt is he um
doesn't matter to me but yeah man I
think it may explain it but if you
required selection then you don't call
it a tractor anymore I think that might
be positive biology mentality see what
you think after I give you my my view
I'm still warming up that's okay but I
haven't given you some ways of thinking
about it alternative ways of thinking
about it I'm still trying to convince
you're here about because I'm making
strong claims about what other people
think which is always a dangerous
position to be in because of course
those people are never in the room
you're kind of making somebody up but I
want to try to convince you that it's
actually there's some truth to this
claim because it's important for what
I'm trying to say this is a review
article that came out 2013
ultra-sensitive Hill equation response
motifs basic amplifiers and molecular
signaling networks this is a beautiful
review article I've truly think it's
very well done these people are from the
center for dose-response modeling the
reason why they're from the center for
dose-response modeling and the writing
an article about molecular biology at
the detailed molecular level is because
dose-response modeling is based on the
hill equation these people are experts
in the hill equation and they're using
their expertise at the molecular level
to explain these patterns so here's one
part from there just one example from
their article you know you've got
inactive form an inactive form this is a
classic explanation from the history of
biochemistry you've got a input that
drives the system from inactive to
active and you've got a repressor that
drives the system from active to
inactive if these two forward if the
forward and back reactions are near
saturation then you get a very strong
switch like behavior biochemically and
this has been known for a long time and
this is one of the classic ones on the
shopping list of potential molecular
explanations it works well known
requires forward and back saturation
here's another nice idea from the
article two key about the hill equation
pattern is that you get low sensitivity
at low input before you get a rapid rise
so what's a simple way to
that molecular Li you can titrate out
the input signal when it's low so here's
the input signal d is a receptor that
binds the input signal with high
affinity so as outcomes in it binds to D
D doesn't do anything just tie traits
out the input signal so you don't get a
response wendy is saturated then L
starts to bind to our which is a
receptor which then transduces a signal
so you can build the hill equation
response very nicely by just titrating
things out it works I have no doubt that
this exists in biology because pretty
much everything that can happen does
happen and here we go I'm sure maybe
your ideas in here I don't know but this
is from their article all the different
alternative motifs that are that they've
reviewed they're not claiming this is
all of them they're just saying here are
some ones that have been discussed
extensively here the two I gave you
here's a bunch of others you can build a
hill equation response from biochemistry
in a large variety of ways the
literature on this both in the
laboratory and theories immense their
micro scale explanations to fit the
pattern in this to summarize in this the
same review article here's a particular
reaction a known biochemical reaction
from real biology there's a hill
equation coefficient and here is which
of the ones on the shopping list is
thought to match that pattern okay so
this is the state of the art is you just
take every example and you match it
figure out the biochemical mechanism and
there's a lot of them okay so biologists
do think this way and it could be right
in each case but I and I don't have an
argument any case but I have a profound
suspicion it is so simple that equation
is so simple and fits the patterns so
well that is a really right always to be
thinking in terms of specific detail
deterministic microscale explanations to
fit those patterns I wondered I really
do wonder and keep on seeing this in my
head now that everybody knows the
central limit theorem but I personally
never get tired of looking at these
curves because to me this is just
amazing okay so what I did this is a
little just a little example these are
probability
functions at the top so you have some x
value the height is the relative
probability we're going to sample from
these distributions 24 8 and 16 times
and add them up by the time you go from
here down to 16 or from this
distribution down to 16 that Gaussian
shape is perfect that pattern is perfect
that's because the Gaussian is the
outcome of the dissipation and loss of
information the only thing that's
retained is roughly speaking the average
deviation from a central location okay
the dissipation of information leads the
perfect pattern by the loss of
information so another way to build a
perfect pattern is to just aggregate a
bunch of things and lose information
okay let's do the same thing but let's
multiply the observations right you know
you're going to get a log normal so you
start with these different things you
multiply random draws from those things
and get a log normal the two main
drivers a pattern are the loss of
information by aggregation and scale
transformation this is a scale
transformation because multiplication is
the sum of the logarithms so this is
just a log transform calcium well
everybody knows that but more general
principle as the dissipation of
information and scale transformation
we'll come back to that point later so
the common explanations are like this
you come up you have a pattern you make
a microscale explanation you fit the
pattern in that way you might be right
but maybe you're not maybe there's some
other way to think about the problem so
all I do is give you a few examples of
an alternative way in which we can
generate this Hill equation pattern
which I think strikes me is more likely
with regard to biological design let's
think in terms of aggregation here we
have a cascade of reactions the input
goes to an output the output forms the
input for the next reaction the output
goes the next reaction here we have a
cascade of 12 reactions we're going to
take Hill coefficients for each reaction
drawn randomly from different
distributions let's draw from this
exponential distribution with a mean of
1.1 for the hill coefficient of 1
point 14 is visually indistinguishable
for makayla's menten kinetics we just
take random draws from this particular
distribution with a mean of 1.14 we
aggregate in a cascade we get a hill
coefficient of 1.7 the hill coefficient
multiplies through a cascade you can get
high hill coefficients from components
that have very low Hill coefficients you
can do the same thing by drawing from
distribution with higher until
coefficients and you get hired Hill
coefficients the point is you're getting
aggregation is leading you to a
significant filled coefficient pattern
you can think of that as the dissipation
of information because in effect this
lower tail here is not is basically not
transducing or transmitting the signal
and as you multiply that you're getting
a weaker and weaker transmission of low
input signals that's a deterministic
model that shows the multiplication of
the hill coefficients it doesn't tell
you where you get a hill coefficient of
greater than one to start with which was
the original puzzle let's imagine a
sloppy component so we know that sells
individual cells can be quite sloppy and
that sometimes we sell when it gets an
input just doesn't do anything it
doesn't react that could because you're
getting stochastic fluctuations and the
reactants they're involved sometimes
cells are in quiescent stage and don't
seem to be doing very much is an
individual cellular level let's just
imagine this is the input signal that's
the output this is the input output
pattern that for low inputs the signal
isn't transmitted occasionally you're
just getting a loss of transmission
because the cell doesn't respond so if
you get a 30 percent chance of no
response at a tiny input and this
failure to respond drops off 20 very
quickly so you're just getting a little
bit of failure for very low inputs the
cells are just a little bit sloppy and
now we do an aggregation of those in a
cascade where we have to 48 of those in
a cascade what happens well by the time
you're up to 8 you've got a very strong
hill coefficient switch like pattern you
aggregate a bunch of sloppy components
that are just a little bit weak at
transmitting low input signals he put
them in a cascade and you're going to
get a perfect tail equation response so
if you're going to design a biological
system or imagine how biology is going
to design
something is biology going to tend to
design things by making very perfect
deterministic microscale generative
processes or is going to slap together a
bunch of sloppy components where the
locus of design is really in the
aggregate structure so my view is that a
lot of problems and regulatory control
have to do with the modulation around
these sort of attractors mine so biology
can modulate the overall input-output
relations by slapping together a bunch
of sloppy components and taking
advantage of the role of aggregation and
giving relatively precise and puts up in
outputs maybe not so different from the
first talk this morning but trying to
focus a bit more on the key aspects of
what things are going on underneath one
last example that's what I'm kind of
fascinated with diffusion-limited
reactions if you take them so this is of
stochastic simulation molecular
simulation of a particular chemical
reaction that I did myself and if you do
this reaction with high diffusion rate
you get Michaela's matt and kinetics if
you look at diffusion limitation however
you get a strong he'll equation response
now diffusion limitation is probably
fairly common in cells because cells are
often crowded sometimes the
concentration of cells are low and
things don't always too few so fast and
within cells now why would diffusion
limited reactions give you a hill
equation response I don't know exactly
that's the problem when you do a
simulation you have to figure out what's
going on but I think the reason why one
of the reasons why is the following
imagine that initially there's a uniform
distribution of a non active molecule
and a uniform distribution of an
incoming signal so we have mass action
potentially ready to go but imagine in a
particular location that the signal
molecule transforms and non active
molecule to an active state that in that
little neighborhood the concentration of
the adaptive molecules is now relatively
lower now as the inactive molecules are
basically measuring devices for the
input because that's what you're using
the output to transformation to the
output or active form as a measurement
you get all the measurement in a local
domain and the system loses sensitivity
because it no longer has the inactive
molecule available to measure a new
input molecule if you have fast
diffusion that all spreads out and you
get perfect spatial uniformity gives you
maximum sensitivity so you lose
sensitivity you lose measurement
capacity you dissipate your ability to
actually acquire information with each
reaction in the diffusion limited
reaction scheme so although there's a
lot of discussion of diffusion limited
reactions in biochemistry when I wrote
to the person who wrote the program
that's to study diffusion limited
reactions and ask them about the hill
equation he said oh isn't that all known
that's just the whatever model you were
going to describe and there's nothing
interesting biochemically and I studied
diffusion limited reactions why would
you be interested in the hill equation
in diffusional interactions that's
already well understood or could you say
what the equations are this is the
simulation oh no I mean I could find in
my paper but I can't say right now
because I don't remember dimensions it
all changes the hill coefficient the
hill coefficient is sensitive to pretty
much every parameter that you can think
of screwing around with that's the point
I mean you know the details we can if
anybody was really interested in details
we can discuss them it's a molecular
simulation it's tedious and boring but
it's there's a reaction is an underlying
reaction which is usually
yeah there's a reaction and can you tell
us what that reaction is I might have
noticed I might have it on a slide a
candle I'll see if it's there so I
showed you three ways in which
information might dissipate within
reactions gives them not claiming that
this is the way it happens but the point
is that it's actually fairly easy to
build a hill equation response from
sloppy components because aggregation
almost inevitably leads to that or
diffusion limited reactions or other
ways in which information to sort of
lost in these systems so one of the key
points that is dissipation of
information is extremely powerful and
here's one of the quiet think is one of
the great quotes in the history of
science from the great mathematician
kolmogorov a fact in fact all
epistemological value of the theory of
probability is based on this that
large-scale random phenomena in their
collective action creates strict
non-random regularity so in terms of
biological design you know take a lot of
sloppy components if you stick them
together you get precision so when we
see precision do we have to look for
micro scale generative mechanisms which
are precise and perfect and difficult to
maintain or does biology modulate using
this principle modulate sloppy
components in terms of its overall
architectural design to achieve route
well to the precise biological function
i'm inclined to think along these lines
another quote from jane's another
favorite author we cannot understand
what is happening until we learn to
think of probability distributions in
terms of their demonstrable information
content so i've been pursuing these
ideas through a variety of articles i
want to make a key point in a second
here just want to mention is the common
patterns of nature just this idea in
general about these attractors there's
many different patterns i mentioned at
the beginning of the talk that
biologists all know the gaussian but if
you give them an exponential
distribution remember yesterday's talked
about random chromosome breakage you
give them an exponential distribution
and they're going to fit something to it
and think they understand what's going
on the exponential distribution is an
attractor if you if you fix the average
and you had everything else be as random
as possible any process that fixes the
average is pretty random is going to be
an exponential distribution so it's
important to understand and recognize
the common patterns if you don't know
the common patterns you can't read
what's going on in nature so I've been
developing this idea through a variety
of articles measurement invariance
entropy and probability and this article
which I developed with my co-author Eric
Smith who is a really great mathematical
physicist and he really deserves the
credit for this but a simple derivation
and classification of common
probabilities to students based on
information symmetry and measurement
scale and I'm emphasizing this because
one of the reasons why only the Gaussian
tends to be recognized is that even in
physics and even in the sort of people
who really know how to do this stuff
which is me there still is not a really
good understanding of what the real
attractors are in terms of pattern so we
all know the Gaussian we know the
log-normal we know a couple of others
but there's actually a wide range of
patterns which recur for example when I
see a gamma distribution which arises
for example in the analysis of large
data sets over and over and over again
many people think oh that's interesting
you know there's a nice pattern I can
explain what's going on there and what I
see is that the gamma is what you expect
if you have a log linear scale and
everything else is as random as possible
let me develop that idea because that's
the last point I want to make remember
here this is scale transformation with a
Gaussian you get a log normal
everybody's got that that's very common
but let's look at the hill equation so
this should literature on the hill
equation is vast but i think that almost
nobody and I'm sure somebody has almost
nobody has ever said the following about
the hill equation let's just look at if
the input is low the denominator is
essentially zero we've got a power law a
power laws of log scale this just says
it locally input the scaling is
logarithmic at high input you've got
saturation which is logarithmic scaling
so you've got log scale log scale and in
between you get a linear zone this is
the simplest expression at expression of
log linear log scaling viognier airlock
scaling everybody does log minier locks
going when you have small numbers and
concentrations in chemistry you're right
10 to the minus 8 10 to the minus 7 10
to the minus
six when you're an intermediate zone you
write 1.1 1.2 1.3 when you're in high
zone you say 10 to six ten to seven ten
to the eighth we all use log lean your
locks giving the hill equation is just
the mathematical expression of log
linear log scaling that is why it's so
common log linear mark scaling and in a
certain amount of dissipation of
information and you tend end up on a
log-linear large scale so when I say I
see a gamma pattern a gamma pattern
probability distribution is what you get
if you have a log linear scale
logarithmic gets small magnitudes and
linear large magnitudes and everything
else is so random and dissipates so much
that all you maintain our average values
at small scale the average of the
logarithm is the geometric mean and at
large values its linear so you get the
arithmetic mean and the Gaussian is
exactly that it's the geometric mean and
the log mean constrained and everything
else is random as they could be so the
common patterns so more deeply all the
common patterns I believe I actually fit
into a hierarchy with regard to
measurement scales and that's what I did
with my colleague Eric Smith is that
we've actually developed an underlying
sense of the relationships between a
variety of measurement scales and it
gets a little bit more complicated than
just log linear but there's a variety of
scalings and I think that you need to be
able to read those patterns in order to
read the patterns of nature and
recognize them so that you don't explain
what is in fact aggregation and
dissipation of information by a complex
explanation now I'm not saying that the
whole world is just based on aggregation
by a lot by what I'm saying is that
these sets incredibly powerful contours
for the nature of pattern and that
design in biology and computational
architectures necessarily follow those
contours and modulated those contours if
you want to understand the computational
architecture of natural systems you have
to understand what those common tractor
patterns are and how biology modulates
around those common attractors so to
summarize the first part of the talk was
about the duality between robustness and
decay and if you think about that what I
was
saying in the first part of the talk is
that as you get systems that overlay on
top of functional biological systems
that protect biology biological systems
from perturbations homeostasis is what
we call it in physiology that what
happens is that you tend to get a decay
in the underlying components because
those components are protected and so
you're going to use cheaper lower
performing components within the system
to get a decay you'll get a tendency for
sloppiness at the microscale but
function at the larger scale then the
second part of talk in essence i turned
it around and i said when you see short
patterns in biological systems you
should be thinking maybe that's the
outcome of the aggregation of sloppy
components to give us precise function
at the system's level so the two
different parts of the talk are actually
sort of flip sides of the same coin
which is that you have to understand the
relation between function at the system
level and the sloppiness of the
component level and understand how
evolutionary dynamics kind of makes a
weird process that in the end gives us
the architectures that we observe in
relation to those two different points
of view that are related to each other
so thank you very much that's what I
think so she's interesting point to what
extent are the components sloppy and i
would say in the cases where people have
actually measured as precisely as
possible these input-output relations it
turns out that the components are in
fact extremely precise right so for
example creates is you know i give it
its a hemoglobin but you can take for
example more physiological even more
physiological jason bacteria like
chemotaxis right every component of that
system I actually agree with the point
remarkably precise so thinking of
proteins is sloppy I think is actually
you know it doesn't seem to be the case
that providers lobby I think I agree
that that's but here's the question and
I don't know the answer so I'm not
saying that I'm right but here's the
question people see what they look for a
biochemist is very interested in in
isolating a system that can be studied
in the laboratory in a precise way
so people only study those biochemical
reactions which have the characteristics
which lead to what you say they don't
start by saying I really want to
understand biological design and here's
and it turns out that this systems kind
of sloppy but I think that's really
important for biological design so I'm
going to study it that does not have
biochemist thick as it just adds is to
find out we know in which cases are the
things more sloppy in which cases there
are they not well that's the question
right right but I'm telling you why in
spite of the fact that that table was in
that review article and I think it's a
beautiful table and I don't think that
any of those scientists are bad
scientists they've seen precision over
and over and over again yes you said you
don't want to give an explanation it's
too complicated but similarly you don't
want to give an explanation of it's too
simple either so I give an example of
the fashion in nature papers on you know
with power laws and scales
redistributions everybody published a
paper something like a time into for
Einstein to respond to letters have this
distribution preference so it gives a
[ __ ] what what is that what is it for
what is it explained to understand that
something takes distribution okay well
it could be something like if there's a
general broad class of microscopic to
macroscopic principles such as
preferential attachment of course that
distributions and that as it is so
hematologic what you're doing is
proposing a broad plants of principles
that can construct distributions and
shouldn't you understand d people or
construct gaussians and now you
understand think they will construct
power laws that's good is that roughly
what you're doing I have no idea what
you're about to say I mean I I've just
said it that's one well that's one
question what he wanted what you want to
do I mean is that roughly what you want
to do to define a broad class of
mechanisms that constructs Hill function
my things no no absolutely not what do
you want to save it I want to understand
biological design I want to look at an
organism see how its put together and
understand how it's come to be that way
I believe that the current approach
which was emphasized very strongly by a
friend back here about the way
biochemist viewed the world although I
think that their contribution is immense
I think it's only a tiny fraction of
what goes on in biological design I
think that that a lot of biological
design is actually based on the
aggregation of sloppy components so you
are dead to find a rule closet
principles which strives that
distribution which is what strong guys
and other people do with this I don't
know I I don't know you're saying
something that you think I'm saying but
I don't hear it so just one comment and
then I guess maybe other parts of
question so my impression was about hill
functions is the general shape that you
see all over the place but exactly that
it's being X to the K here and 1 minus X
cool here you know you do develop it's
nothing you should look like ya know
some cases it does so into question
which is one mainly trying to explain
these start search steep curves in the
middle for this extent highly sensitive
behavior is a good question it so
there's a very simple general mechanism
that gives you things that look like
this as far as the general features
which can be you can make shorter and
less shocked by changing parameter and
that's just to observe that one of the
very generic things that come out of all
kinds of things is actual by stability
not wear this looks like this but way
it's actually by saying we're just able
here in stable thing later and you can
change something a little foot between
them that doesn't flirt without changing
if you take that then you add sloppiness
so you can add stochasticity and the
circuit city are faster on the
timescales then you're the new that
you're looking at then you get something
with arbitrary shapes the arbitrary
Steve and level by just how much like a
sister you have all right so it's a very
general thing for could be no you know
double pair of the fixed points very
gentle and the circuit icity in there as
well I mean does that count as an
explanation of the kind you're looking
for or is that no all common patterns
are common for one reason because
there's a huge number of mechanisms that
generate that outcome so if you look and
you think I've got a way of explaining
that I'm sure you do I'm sure everybody
learns I have no biochemistry in there I
just say absolutely generically you get
by stability and then you would
absolutely get fluctuations and
therefore absolute genetic you get those
kind of curves if that works for you
that's fine i don't i'm sure what your
question is though but why is that not
is why is that not something of the kind
you looking I'm looking for
understanding organism will design i'm
working for how organisms are put
together and I think that organisms are
put together by taking advantage of the
fact that there are powerful attractors
that set natural contours of pattern the
dynamical systems that have staked by
stable is a natural attractor in any
reasonable sense of attraction okay then
it works well we should probably have
lunch and continue discussion Thank You
doesn't get maybe we should come back
the top us one